hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live Masken Ausgangssperren 2G 3G 2g+
erinnert ihr euch alles Maßnahmen mit
denen wir versucht haben das
Corona-Virus irgendwie in Schach zu
halten was hat das aber am Ende wirklich
gebracht welche corona-maßnahmen haben
am Ende wirklich geholfen ein Ausschuss
soll das klären welche Maßnahmen da
wirksam waren und überhaupt wie wir
abgeschnitten haben in der
corona-pandemie wie die Bundesregierung
abgeschnitten hat und Sachverständige
haben sich das also genau angeschaut und
präsentieren heute ihre Ergebnisse nach
denen sich dann Bund und Länder im
besten Falle eben auch die Leitlinien
ableiten sollen für die corona-politik
im Herbst ab Herbst und wir sind live
dabei wir gehen also live drauf in auf
diese Pressekonferenz wenn dieser
Ausschuss seinen Bericht vorstellt das
sollte ungefähr in acht Minuten
passieren und wir zeigen diese
Pressekonferenz live wir können auch mal
schauen jetzt gerade passiert
hoffentlich noch nichts dann haben wir
ich noch ein bisschen Zeit darüber zu
sprechen vielleicht schalten wir mal
kurz in den Saal und wir sehen noch
nichts ein leeres Pult aber wunderbar
das gibt uns ein bisschen Zeit zu
sprechen darüber was wir dazu erwarten
haben von diesem Papier was also die
Pandemie Regeln bewerten soll seit 2020
das ist ja schon eine ganze Weile und
wir können sprechen nicht nur mit
unserer hauptstadtkorrespondentin Andrea
Maurer die das ganze auch genau sich
anschaut sondern nach der
Pressekonferenz sprechen wir mit dem
Epidemiologen Klaus Stöhr er selbst ist
Mitglied dieses Sachverständigen
Ausschuss und außerdem kritisiert er
Schaf die aktuelle corona-politik von
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach aber
natürlich auch schon vorher bevor
Lauterbach Gesundheitsminister wurde war
die corona-pandemie in der Kritik und
natürlich auch das was uns zwei Jahre
lang umgetrieben hat da war ein anderer
Gesundheitsminister noch am Zug Jens
Spahn und er hatte wohl schon geahnt
dass die corona-politik einmal scharf
kritis werden würde wir erinnern uns mal
und schauen in einen Ton von ihnen von
ihm
wir werden in der politischen Debatte
und auch in der medialen Debatte nach
dieser corona-
weil das glaube ich in der
bundesrepublikanischen Geschichte noch
nie es gegeben hat
dass unter so großen Unsicherheiten
in so kurzer Zeit so weitgehende
Entscheidungen getroffen werden mussten
Maurer hoffe ich da sehen wir sie gleich
Andrea Maurer unsere Korrespondentin im
Hauptstadtstudio Andrea wir haben gerade
den Ton von Jens Spahn gehört das ist
der ex-gesundheitsminister aber wessen
Entscheidungen ist jetzt heute mehr
unter Beschuss die Entscheidung von Jens
Spahn die von Karl Lauterbach was ist da
zu erwarten
ja also was vor allem zu erwarten ist
wir haben jetzt diesen Bericht hier
schon vorab vorgelegt bekommen ist ein
sehr sehr kritischer Auseinandersetzung
mit den politischen
Entscheidungsprozessen mit den Maßnahmen
mit der Datengrundlage in dieser
Pandemie das ist doch schon ein wir
haben es wurde immer gesagt es sei ein
Corona Zeugnis und dieses Zeugnis ist
nicht gut es ist tatsächlich so dass
Jens Spahn ja diesen Sachverständigenrat
ins Leben gerufen hat er ist also
sozusagen derjenige gewesen der diese
Evaluierung auf den Weg gebracht hat
aber es ist eben jetzt nicht nur eine
Evaluierung zu den Maßnahmen in seiner
Amtszeit sondern natürlich auch zu dem
was in der Amtszeit des aktuellen
Gesundheitsministers passiert ist es ist
ein
harsches Zeugnis über politische
Kommunikation und mich ja auch schon
gesagt habe über Entscheidungsprozesse
besonders hart wird da ins Gericht
gegangen mit der bund-länderrunde ein
Gremium das sozusagen nicht vom
Parlament legitimiert sei das hinter
verschlossenen Türen get hat das war ja
sowohl unterschwan als auch unter
Lauterbach der Fall und es wird auch mit
diesem gesetzlichen Instrumentarium ins
Gericht gegangen der
Notlage also der epidemischen Notlage
das sei nicht der angemessene rechtliche
Rahmen um einer Pandemie zu begegnen
[Musik]
bis zur Pressekonferenz haben wir noch
ein bisschen Zeit also auch Zeit noch
einmal zurückzuschauen auf all die
Maßnahmen die Bund und Länder
beschlossen haben Franziska von
tiesenhausen hat das mal für uns
zusammengefasst
mit zu den ersten corona-maßnahmen
gehört die Schließung von Schulen und
Kindertagesstätten Kinder müssen vorerst
zu Hause betreut und beschult werden
gleichzeitig müssen viele Arbeitnehmer
ins Homeoffice wechseln für viele
Familien eine große Belastung mit der
Einführung der maskenpflicht soll die
Ausbreitung des Virus gebremst werden
der mund-nasen-
Hochzeiten Geburtstage und andere
private Feiern müssen ausfallen weil sie
als Treiber der Pandemie gelten sogar
Spielplätze werden zeitweise gesperrt in
der Hoffnung das Virus so in Schach
halten zu können über Monate gelten
strikte kontaktbeschränkungen wer
dagegen verstößt muss mit hohen
Bußgeldern rechnen das öffentliche Leben
wird vorübergehend auf Eis gelegt
Gastronomie Einzelhandel und
Kultureinrichtungen bleiben geschlossen
zeitweise gilt deutschlandweit sogar
eine nächtliche Ausgangssperre um die
Verbreitung des Coronavirus einzudämmen
gelockert werden die Maßnahmen nur
vorsichtig und schrittweise vielerorts
gibt es Zugangsbeschränkungen und
Verwirrung über die erlassenen 3G und
2g-regeln
[Musik]
so und wir schauen noch mal rein in den
Saal ob die Pressekonferenz ob sich da
schon was tut auf dem Podium nicht dass
wir das verpassen aber es ist also noch
alles ruhig soll aber losgehen in drei
Minuten und 3 Minuten haben wir also
noch mit unserer Hauptstadtstudio
Korrespondentin Andrea Maurer darauf zu
schauen und zu sprechen Andrea was ist
denn bereits durchgesickert was in
diesem Bericht stehen soll du hattest
eben schon einen kleinen Blick darauf
geworfen was weißt du noch
nun im Grunde genommen steht in diesem
Bericht entschuldigung ich höre hier
gerade mich doppelt ich muss das mal
kurz rausnehmen in diesem Bericht steht
im Grunde genommen keine klare Aussage
zu der Wirksamkeit von Maßnahmen bis auf
Maske tragen würde ich sagen also
im da steht dass in der Frühphase
beispielsweise lockdowns sicher sinnvoll
waren dass sie aber schnell ihre Wirkung
verlieren dass
kontaktbeschränkungen nicht ganz klar
ist wie wie weit sie wirksam sind ich
habe bei geschlossenen Schulen gelesen
das ist eigentlich strittig ist
inwiefern das eben wirksam war weil da
ja eben auch Maßnahmen parallel
stattgefunden haben also Schüler haben
ja auch die ganze Zeit noch Maske
getragen es gab eben diese
anlasslosen Testungen die auch zu hohen
inzidenzwerten überhaupt unter den
Schülern geführt haben so steht es in
diesem Bericht gleichzeitig waren die
Kollateralschäden enorm also für Frauen
wird da gesagt für Kinder
ist sozusagen eine ganze Abwägung
Maßnahmen werden in diesem Bericht auch
ins Verhältnis gesetzt zu den
gesellschaftlichen Folgen die sie hatten
bei 2G und 3g-regeln wird gesagt das
angesichts der aktuellen unicronvariante
es eben vielleicht viel sinnvoller wäre
das alle sich testen als dass man
impfnachweise vorzeigt weil im Grunde
genommen ja die Übertragbarkeit auch bei
geimpften in dieser Variante gegeben ist
also es ist bis auf die Tatsache Maske
tragen und da eben auch noch mal die
Kritik dass eine schlecht sitzende Maske
auch nicht schützt gibt es eigentlich zu
keiner Maßnahme die von der Politik
eingeführt wurde eine eindeutige Aussage
dass sie ein sinnvollen Nutzen hatte und
das ist angesichts der Tatsache dass
dieser Bericht natürlich auch eine
politische Dimension hat natürlich
weitgreifend Andrea an dieser Stelle und
erwartet
auf Basis dieses Berichts will auch nun
Regierung will das Parlament weiterhin
entscheiden und Andrea bleibt es eben
abzuwarten wie jetzt auch Politik auf
diesen Bericht der jetzt hier gleich
vorgestellt wird reagiert und er wird
genau jetzt vorgestellt und wir schalten
rüber und hören gemeinsam zu
verstehen Sie mich
hallo versteht man mich
man versteht sie hallo hören sie mich
es grünt so grün wenn Spaniens Blumen
blühen
herzlich willkommen der BZ
gut wir können starten
sehr geehrte Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der Medien ich heiße Sie im
Saal hier und online herzlich willkommen
zu dieser Pressekonferenz auf der der
Bericht des sachverständigenausschusses
zur Evaluation der Rechtsgrundlagen und
Maßnahmen der pandemiepolitik in
Deutschland vorgestellt wird wir sind
heute an einem eher ungewöhnlichen Ort
für einen solchen Pressetermin
normalerweise würde er in den
Räumlichkeiten der Bundespressekonferenz
stattfinden aus terminlichen und
logistischen Gründen musste der Termin
heute allerdings hier WZB stattfinden
ich möchte noch kurz darauf hinweisen
dass aus gesundheitlichen Gründen der
Vorsitzende der Kommission Herr
Professor Stefan Huster heute leider
nicht teilnehmen kann an seiner Stelle
begrüße ich die
stellvertretendenvorsitzenden Frau
Professorin Helga Rübsamen Chef und Frau
Professorin Andrea Kiesling die uns aus
Frankfurt zugeschaltet ist
ich begrüße außerdem hier im Saal die
Kommissionsmitglieder Frau Professorin
Jutta allmending Allmendinger zu meiner
Rechten
Herrn Professor Christoph Schmidt zu
meiner Linken und Herrn Professor
Hendrik streek ebenfalls zu meiner
Rechten
bevor wir starten ein paar kurze
Hinweise ich bitte die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die online per Zoom
zugeschaltet sind zu überprüfen ob Ihr
Klarname und das Medium dass sie
vertreten in ihrem zungenfenster
angezeigt wird falls nicht bitte ändern
Sie die Angaben entsprechend und ich
hoffe Sie haben Verständnis dass ich
nachher im Frageteil nur diejenigen
aufrufen kann deren klarnahmen lesbar
ist vielen Dank bitte achten Sie auch
darauf dass ihr Ton jetzt ausgeschaltet
ist
die Anwesenden und zugeschalteten
Kommissionsmitglieder werden im ersten
Teil dieser Konferenz einen Überblick
über die Arbeit und die Ergebnisse der
Kommission geben sie orientieren sich
dabei im Wesentlichen an der Struktur
des Berichts der Ihnen vorliegt danach
ab ca 12:30 Uhr gehen wir zum Frageteil
über und die Pressekonferenz endet dann
um 13 Uhr jetzt übergebe ich das Wort an
Frau Rübsamen Chef bitteschön ja vielen
Dank auch von meiner Seite ein
herzliches Willkommen und an Herrn
Professor Huster den ich ja hier als
Vorsitzender der Kommission vertrete an
dieser Stelle noch mal alle guten
Wünsche für baldige Genesung wir sind
hier im September letzten Jahres
aufgefordert worden oder gebeten worden
gemäß Paragraph 5 Absatz 9
Infektionsschutzgesetz die Regelungen
und deren Auswirkungen zu evaluieren und
dabei geht es um diverse Maßnahmen die
nach dem Ausbruch der Pandemie mit den
Ziel eingeführt worden die Überlastung
des Gesundheitswesens zu vermeiden und
die Gesundheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu schützen zu schützen mehr als
zwei Jahre nach dem Beginn der Pandemie
soll der vorliegende Bericht nun
entsprechend Antworten auf diese Fragen
geben die Ansprüche an die Kommission
und an den Bericht sind hoch ziel ist es
ein wesentlichen Beitrag dazu zu leisten
EntscheidungsträgerInnen und
Entscheidungsträgern in Politik und
Verwaltung eine informierte solide
Grundlage für zukünftige Entscheidungen
und Maßnahmen und Strategien zu gehen
also gerade keine Abrechnung mit Politik
wie man bereits lesen konnte es geht
also ganz klar darum den Auftrag zu
erfüllen
mit dem vorliegenden Daten die da sind
und man muss sagen dass die Erfüllung
dieses Auftrags dadurch erheblich
erschwert wurde dass wir eben zu
Bewertung erst zwei Jahr nach beginnen
der Maßnahmen aufgefordert worden sind
und dass es fern auch nicht gelang seit
dem Beginn der Pandemie eine
ausreichende stringente und begleitende
Datenerhebung zu etablieren und mit
diesen Einschränkungen muss die
Kommission aber auch die Gesellschaft
umgehen
hinweisen möchte ich noch darauf dass
die Kommission auch Empfehlung zu Themen
ausgesprochen hat die nicht zentraler
Bestandteil unseres Auftrags waren die
uns aber essentiell wichtig erschienen
zum Beispiel zur Kommunikation in
Krisensituationen und auch möchte ich
festhalten dass in der knappenzeit es
leider nicht möglich war auch
Empfehlungen zu Maßnahmen der
pandemienbekämpfung hinsichtlich
Impfstoffen Diagnostiker und Medikamente
abzugeben natürlich auch sehr wichtig
wären
bevor wir nun durch die Empfehlung gehen
lassen Sie mich noch mal betonen das ist
von großer Bedeutung ist zu
unterscheiden in welcher Phase der
pandemie-maßnahmen ergriffen werden und
was ihr Ziel ist am Anfang wird man
versuchen die Ausbreitung eines Erregers
Lokal zu begrenzt containmentphase nennt
man das und gelingt es nicht geht man in
die Phase über wobei die Folgen
versucht zu vermeiden und das ist dann
die sogenannte medication Phase ich
glaube dass das immer sehr wichtig ist
sich diese diese Bewegung innerhalb der
Pandemie und die Veränderungen der Ziele
vor Augen zu halten wir werden nun im
Einzelnen Zusammenfassung zu den
Kapiteln geben und ich darf Professor
Schmidt bitten die Ergebnisse zu den
Grundlagen der Evaluation und dem
Datenmanagement zusammenzufassen vielen
Dank
ja dann übernehme ich gerne nahtlos es
war uns von Anfang an klar es wird zum
Anfang im Herbst des vergangenen Jahres
zusammengetreten sind den umfassenden
Bestand an wissenschaftlichen durch
begutachtungsprozesse geprüftten
Einzelbelegen für die Wirksamkeit die
Nebenwirkungen und Kosten einzelner
Maßnahmen oder garmast von Maßnahmen
bündeln die man als Wissenschaftler nur
noch mehr nach den etablierten Regeln
der Kunst nur noch in Anführungsstrichen
zusammenführen muss diesen Bestand gibt
es nicht es gibt viele einzelbeläge es
gibt viel Evidenz es gibt viel Literatur
aber es ist nicht so dass wir einfach
die
bestehenden Körper an Evidenz
zusammenführen können und haben unsere
Aufgabe erledigt warum gibt es den nicht
nun das liegt am Zusammenspiel von
Wissenschaft und Politik also
insbesondere muss eine muss die Politik
in einer Krise wenn sie sich nachher
prüfen lassen will wissen gutes vor wir
müssen sehr sehr gute Absicht dann muss
sie Politik Schritt haltend bereits oder
bereits zu Beginn die Voraussetzungen
dafür schaffen nur dann kann es eine
Schritt haltende und Retrospektive
Evaluation im vollen Umfang geben das
heißt also die Konzepte müssen stimmen
von Anfang an muss man sich fragen was
sind denn eigentlich die Fragen die wir
nachher beantwortet wissen wollen die
Daten müssen bereitgestellt werden in
einer Art und Weise oder erhoben werden
in der Art und Weise die diese
Beantwortung nachher ermöglicht und es
muss Schritt haltend auch die die
begrenzte Wirkmächtigkeit staatlichen
Handels klar kommuniziert werden denn
wofür braucht man eine Evaluation daher
um zu sehen was funktioniert und was
nicht funktioniert
das haben wir gewusst aber darauf zu
warten bis dieser Bestand der arbeitet
wird also je stark je größer die
Flughöhe der Frage die umfassender die
Fragestellung desto weniger wird das als
Nebenprodukt des krisenhandels verfügbar
werden es muss wie gesagt gestaltet
werden darauf zu warten bedeutet man
käme für politisches Handeln zu spät
also die Wissenschaft muss auch
pragmatisch genug sein Antworten auch zu
geben die Imperfekt sind die auf
imperfekter Datenlage auch beruhen und
nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen den
Stand der Dinge zusammenzufassen immer
mit dem Blick auf die Vorläufigkeit und
genau das haben wir uns vorgenommen wir
haben Evidenz gesammelt nach bestem
Wissen und Gewissen und nach intensiver
Diskussion bewertet eingeordnet und
bewusst dabei die Multidisziplinarität
unseres Tuns genutzt wir sind zudem
einen Schritt zurückgetreten das ist
mehr der methodische teil und haben uns
gefragt was sind denn eigentlich in
einer solchen Situation die richtigen
Fragen wie stellt man die richtigen
Fragen wie kann man sie im Prinzip
beantworten in einer so komplexen
Situation dass viele Dinge einander
überlagern zusammen irgendwie in einem
Paket nur wirken und nicht isoliert
betrachtet werden können das haben wir
an den Anfang gestellt und wir haben aus
juristischer Sicht diskutiert ganz im
gleichen pragmatischen Sinne wie das
bisherige Vorgehen einzuordnen ist und
welche Vorschläge für weiteres Vorgehen
auszuarbeiten sind es ist also keine
Generalabrechnung mit dem bisherigen so
nach dem Motto jetzt sagen wir mal was
Sache ist und dann sind wir fertig
sondern ist es eher ein Neuanfang eines
noch besser fundierten Diskurses darf
ich kurz die Ergebnisse von Kapitel 3
und 4 oder die die schlaglichte auf
Kapitel 3 und Kapitel 4 setzen Kapitel 3
widmet sich nicht zuletzt der Frage was
ist denn eigentlich die richtige Frage
wie kann man überhaupt an die richtige
Frage danach stellen was staatliches
Handeln auslöst was ist denn eigentlich
die gegensituation ist die eine
Situation mit weniger staatlichem
Handeln mit anderen monatlichen handeln
mit überhaupt keinen staatlichen
Eingriffen das klingt alles viel
einfacher als es in der praktischen
Umsetzung ist um dann ein Studiendesign
zu verwenden dass diese Fragen zumindest
mal näherungsweise erlaubt zu stellen
ineffiziente und unwirksame Maßnahmen
enttarnt und wirksamer als solche
identifiziert braucht man statistische
begleitdaten umfassend und
schritthaltend ausgewertet man muss die
qualitätsstaatlichen Handelns zudem auch
nicht quantitativ überprüfen und
quantitative statistische Analysen
durchführen dass das möglich ist solche
großen Pakete so zu behandeln das haben
wir bei den harzreformen beispielsweise
gesehen und wie Frau Rübsamen Chef ist
schon andeutete es ist jetzt nicht zu
spät es ist zwar spät aber es ist nicht
zu spät noch mehr an einem
übergreifenden Konzept für Public Health
Epidemiologie und klinische Forschung zu
arbeiten dafür braucht es Kapitel 4
Daten die Datengrundlage und das
Datenmanagement sind nicht Teil unserer
Aufgabe oder unseres Auftrags
ursprünglich gewesen wir sehen es eben
aus
genannten geschilderten Umständen heraus
als zwingend an dass wir uns auch damit
beschäftigen es gibt ein großen Bestand
an Daten was will man eigentlich von den
Daten was erwartet man zum einen möchte
man das indemische potenzialschritt
haltend begleiten man möchte die schwere
Profile sehen die ressourcenbelastungen
versuchen zu verstehen um politisches
Handeln darauf auszurichten und dafür
gibt es viel die Meldearten des IfSG die
gemeldeten Testergebnisse die Belegung
der Intensivstationen allein die
Verknüpfung die Datenbereitstellung
Verknüpfung die Erhebung und das
verfügbar machen sind keine Selbstläufer
da müsste noch mehr geschehen
was hat man gemacht in der Krise man hat
sich sehr auf Modell gestütztes auf ex
ante Simulationen also Modellierung
verlassen das ist ein wichtiges Tool
aber worüber wir insbesondere reden in
unserer Kommission ist ja die rückwärts
gewann die retrospekt ich
rückwärtsgewandt im Sinne von altbacken
sondern die Retrospektive Bewertung was
ist tatsächlich dabei rausgekommen nicht
was kommt vermutlich dabei raus wenn
Menschen sich so verhalten wie wir es
vermuten in einer exantesimulation es
gibt vieles was wir da optimieren können
die Digitalisierung dis
Gesundheitswesens erfordert eine
entsprechende infrastrukturelle
Initiative Datenschutz und
datensicherheitsprobleme sind zu lösen
ein wichtiger Punkt ist Mut zur
Stichprobe vollerhebungen zu haben die
spät kommen oder unvollständig
fehlerhaft im Endeffekt erhoben werden
ist vielleicht nicht so hilfreich für
politisches Handeln wie auf
repräsentativen Stichproben und
geeigneten aus diesen ermittelten
Indikatoren zu arbeiten da wären wir der
Meinung da könnte man sehr viel oder
sollte sehr viel mehr machen
insbesondere auch
ressourcenbelastungen Personalfragen etc
im Gesundheitswesen miterheben auf
kleinräumiger Ebene und das in
Plattformen für multidisziplinäre
Forschung zur Verfügung stellen danke
dann darf ich weitermachen zunächst mal
freue ich mich sehr über Ihr Interesse
ich freue mich auch sehr dass ich die
Ehre hatte in dieser Kommission
mitzuarbeiten die eine tolle Kommission
war was auch immer man schreibt sie war
toll und ich darf sagen wenn ich jetzt
über Risiko Kommunikation spreche dass
ich eine mitverantwortliche für dieses
Kapitel bin aber an dieser Stelle ganz
herzlich
Herrn Professor Rosenbrock grüßen möchte
der leider auch an Corona erkrankt ist
warum haben wir uns mit der
Risikokommunikation beschäftigt genauso
wie mit Daten und Modellen ist das einer
der zentralen präventiven Ansätze die
wir jetzt richtig aufstellen müssen um
den nächsten Pandemien und anderen
Krisen und davon haben wir im Moment
wahrlich sehr viele sachgerecht
zielgerichte vor und entgegenstehen zu
können und wenn ich das sage so weil die
Risikokommunikation einen zentral
wichtigen Baustein darstellt um ver in
die Wissenschaft überhaupt zu generieren
und das Wissen über Wissenschaft
Vertrauen in die Politik aber auch das
Vertrauen was das Zusammenleben der
Gesellschaft mit uns und über uns
betrifft das ist genauso wichtig wie
eine wichtige Säule der
Wissenschaftskommunikation der
Risikokommunikation ist dass man die
Menschen überhaupt erst mal in die Lage
versetzt bewusste Entscheidungen zu
treffen was also arbeiten wir in diesem
Kapitel heraus zunächst mal es ist
wichtig dass wir schnell informieren es
ist wichtig dass wir informieren auch
mit dem Risiko auf dass wir immer
hinweisen müssen dass ja die
Nachrichtenlage dass das was wir wissen
sich auch verändern kann dass wir also
in einer Woche was ganz anderes sagen
müssen weil wir mehr wissen als jetzt
also die Veränderbarkeit des Wissens wir
müssen viel transparente und mit
besseren Maßzahlen arbeiten die grafisch
darstellen mit einer leichten Sprache
wir müssen Sie den Bevölkerungsgruppen
gehen aufsuchen die wir allzu leicht
vergessen in unserer Kommunikation im
Allgemeinen aber gerade auch in Zeiten
von Krisen und Pandemien wir brauchen
einen partizipativen Ansatz keinen von
oben nach unten weil wir wissen dass das
die Menschen heute nicht mehr mitnimmt
und wir müssen tatsächlich auch ehrlich
sein wir müssen darstellen was für
Chancen bestimmte Maßnahmen haben aber
auch was für Risiken bestimmte Maßnahmen
haben das gehört zu dem Diskurs dazu
genauso wie zu einem Diskurs dazu gehört
dass wir abweichende Meinungen sehr sehr
ernst nehmen
wenn wir das machen dann heißt es dass
viele Organisationen zusammenarbeiten
müssen und was meine ich mit vielen
Organisationen das sind natürlich die
Krankenkassen die da mehr hätten tun
können es sind natürlich die
Sportvereine die oft viel näher an den
Menschen dran sind das sind die
Gewerkschaften arbeitgebervertretungen
wir müssen da viel stärker in den
jeweiligen man sagt ja oft zu schönen
Blasen in denen die Menschen sind
reinkommen und Wissen zu den Menschen
bringen und nicht warten bis sie
irgendwie zu uns geflogen kommen an die
Türe klopfen und sagen wie war das jetzt
das ist das was ich dazu zu sagen habe
wir haben es vorangestellt weil es in
der Tat eines der Dinge ist die wir
sofort anzupacken haben im Sinne einer
guten public health Initiative so wie
sie auch im Koalitionsvertrag schon da
gelegt ist
ja vielen Dank ich möchte mich generell
einmal erstmal bedanken vor allem bei
der für die konstruktive Mitarbeit
Zusammenarbeit im Team bei der
Geschäftsstelle die mit in die Nacht
mitgearbeitet hat am Ende und vor allem
auch dem WZB die jetzt quasi unsere
Pressestelle übernommen haben weil wir
haben gar keine Pressestelle und in
kürzester Zeit hier quasi einem große
Pressekonferenz organisiert hat was uns
übrigens auch ermöglicht hat eine
fristgerechte Abgabe zu haben gestern
was Herr Schmidt festgestellt hat trifft
natürlich am deutlichsten auf die
getroffenen Maßnahmen zu wir haben keine
kontrafaktische Realität wir haben eine
schlechte Datenlage es gibt über 200.000
Publikationen zu Kurve 19 und weniger
haben aber den Evidenzgrad den man sich
eigentlich wünschen würde für so eine
Evaluation idealerweise würde man auch
ein systematisches Review durchführen
dass es aber in dieser Form eigentlich
nicht machbar
das Kapitel ist daher so aufgebaut dass
wir erstmal den erhofften Effekt
beschreiben dann die intendierten
Wirkung also die Evidenz für die
intendierten Wirkung dann die Evidenz
für die unintendierten Wirkung also
quasi die Nebenwirkung wenn man das so
beschreiben würde und die daraus
abgeleiteten Handlungsempfehlungen wir
haben uns folgenden Themen gewidmet
einmal den Lockdown und den
lockdown-maßnahmen als Maßnahmenbündel
die Öffnung nach Zweige und 3g-regeln
kontaktnahverfolgung Quarantäne
Isolation Test und Schulschließung wir
haben uns nicht den Impfungen gewidmet
wir haben hier die Ständige
Impfkommission die konstant und
gewissenhaft dauerhaft eine Bewertung
durchführte und das wollten wir auch in
der Hand der stikolassen und auch eine
Gegenüberstellung von zum Beispiel
Schließung von Kulturveranstaltungen
Sportveranstaltungen im Vergleich zu
Schließung von Restaurants werden sie
nicht im Bericht finden werden
da das alles Maßnahmenbündel
gleichzeitig fahren das können wir
einfach nicht bewerten wir legen auch
keine Tabelle vor was richtig oder
falsch ist wir sagen auch nicht das ist
gut dass es schlecht sondern wir
versuchen diesen Graubereich den es da
einfach gibt in der Evaluation
auszuleuchten und damit in der Zukunft
und auch für zukünftige Wellen
Entscheidungsträger die Müll zum
Beispiel in die Frage nach den lockdowns
im Grunde sind das wie eben schon mal
angedeutet Maßnahmen Bündel wir können
die nicht mehr auseinander rechnen es
ist unmöglich es wurde alles
gleichzeitig ergriffen man kann das zwar
ein Modellierungen machen aber jedes
Modell hat eben auch seine Probleme und
wir können auch schon schlecht Länder
Vergleiche machen da jedes Land auch mit
einer anderen lockdown-kultur reagiert
und wir haben deswegen in diesem Bereich
nur korrelativ und modellbasiertes
wissen aber es gibt hier ein großes aber
das möchte ich jetzt auch mal deutlicher
hervorstellen es gibt eine biologische
und physikalische Plausibilität vor und
es gibt kein Zweifel dass wenn wir
unsere Kontakte reduzieren dass wir auch
die ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeiten
reduzieren so ist das einfach weil das
weil das Virus sich eben von Mensch zu
Mensch übertragen wird und gerade zu
Beginn einer Pandemie ist es sinnvoll
die Übertragung in der Bevölkerung
soweit es geht zu reduzieren um dem
Gesundheitssystem den Spielraum zu geben
um sich zu Wappen für die Anzahl an
Infektionen also wer wenn erst wenige
Menschen infiziert sind hat es einen
besonderen Effekt aber lockdowns wirken
eben auch nur denn der Mensch mitmacht
je länger ein Lockdown dauert und je
weniger Menschen bereit sind die
Maßnahmen mitzutragen das haben einige
Studien gezeigt desto geringer ist der
Effekt und umso mehr schwerer werden
eben auch die unerwünschten Wirkung
auf Deutschland wäre das im übrigen die
erste Welle also die Phase des
Containments von den unintendierten
Wirkungen können Sie nachlesen da gibt
es viele eben auch im Gesundheitsbereich
das können wir an dieser Stelle kann ich
das aber nicht umreißen Öffnungen nach
zwei G3 geregel auch hier können wir
keine klare Effektgröße benennen da eben
auch hier Maßnahmenbündel gleichzeitig
ergriffen wurden aber auch hier stellt
sich eben noch mal mehr die Komplexität
einer Evaluation da da wir nicht nur zu
unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten
unterschiedlich Varianten hatten und
dadurch auch unterschiedliche
impfstoffwirkungen hatten und wir einen
ganz klaren zeiteffekt dann auch mit
drin haben
aber wenn wir jetzt nach vorne schauen
und jetzt nach uns Omicron speziell
anschauen dann wissen wir dass es ein
Effekt geben muss in den ersten zwei
drei Wochen für die für eine 2g-regeln
nach Impfung und nach Genesung aber
dieser Effekt sehr schnell verlischt und
dann nicht mehr vorhanden ist auch der
erhoffte Effekt des sekundäre Effekt
eines notchings also des anstoßens dass
man sich impfen lässt kann eigentlich in
den Studien nicht abgelesen werden in
allen Ländern in denen es
Zugangsbeschränkungen gegeben hat für
nur für geimpfte hat es nicht den
erhofften geweckt gegeben dass die
Menschen sich mehr haben impfen lassen
also wenn man in Zukunft über
Zugangsbeschränkungen nachdenken sollte
aus der Politik ist in Anbetracht der
leichten Übertragbarkeit der derzeitigen
Impfstoffe eigentlich nur mit einem
tagesaktuellen Test im Moment zu
arbeiten
ich überspringe die Kontaktpersonen
Nachverfolgung auf Kunden der Zeit aber
wir noch einmal auf die Masken eingehen
Masken wirken das muss man deutlich
sagen das Wissen aus epidemonischen und
Erkenntnissen in tiriaexperimentellen
Bestätigung zeigen einfach dass Masken
eine Wirkung haben daher können Masken
auch ein wirksames Instrument in der
Pandemie gekämpfung sein aber es gibt
leider deutliche Unterschiede zwischen
der Evidenz des Effekts des Mastens aus
kontrollierten Studien und den Effekt in
der Praxis es wird deutlich dass eine
schlecht sitzende und nicht eng
angepasste Maske kein ein verminderten
bis keinen Effekt hat was im Grunde
darauf hinausläuft dass der Maskenträger
auch die Maske tragen will weil
ansonsten hat die Maske auch keinen
Effekt
und der Effekt einer Maske ist eben vor
allem dann da in hochprävalenzgebieten
hochpräventsbedingungen nicht wenn
niedrig Prävalenzen vorhanden sind
hier wird eben auch deutlich mal wieder
die Kommunikation deswegen hat Frau
einem Dinger das hervorgestellt und
wir äußern uns auch nicht zur
ffp2-massen das da sehen wir im Moment
nicht den Effekt der auch hofft wird aus
den Evidenzen sondern da ist es einmal
naja stärker so dass wenn die Maske
getragen richtig getragen wird hat sie
einen starken Effekt aber nicht eben in
der Praxis bisher ableitbar da sollte
sich eine gesonderte Kommission einmal
mit beschäftigen zu Schulschließungen
ganz zum Schluss ein sehr emotionales
Thema für viele und es gibt zahlreiche
Stellungnahmen dazu auf die wir auch
alle hinweisen aber aufgrund der
Wichtigkeit des Themas können wir das
nicht in voller Gänze beurteilen in
Deutschland waren im internationalen
Vergleich waren die Schulen um 38 Wochen
geschlossen und liegt damit im Vergleich
im Mittelfeld
auch hier kann der genaue Effekt von
Schulschließungen nicht aus den Daten
einfach abgelesen werden auch an Schulen
gab es Maßnahmenbündel auch in der Zeit
gab es Maßnahmen Gründe und auch hier
greift eben die Frage nach der
biologischen physikalischen
Plausibilität zusätzlich erschwerend
kommt der Unterschied dass bei
unterschiedlichen Varianten Kinder und
Erwachsene sich unterschiedlich stark
infizieren bei Omicron sehen wir zum
Beispiel diesen Unterschied den wir am
Anfang in der Welle gesehen haben in der
Infektiosität bei Kindern sehen wir bei
ormichon eigentlich eine ähnliche
Infektiosität von Kindern und
Erwachsenen daher kann hier auch nicht
abschließend von der Evidenz auch wenn
sie plausibel ist nicht die Effektgröße
definiert werden und ich übergebe hier
an Frau einem Dinger für die
unintendierten Wirkung ja
hier kommt die Sozialwissenschaftlerin
ins Spiel und ich möchte mal diese
Nebenwirkungen in drei große Felder
unterteilen die ersten zwei Unternehmen
ich und mit der Wirtschaft schließt
natürlich unser Wirtschaftsexperte
Christoph Schmidt ab es geht um die
individuellen folgen zunächst mal wir
haben hier starke Evidenzen überhaupt
gar keine Frage was Schulschließungen
machen mit Kindern aber mit den Kindern
sind ja auch immer die Eltern verbunden
und haben in einem Kapitel dargestellt
wie stark die psychischen Auswirkungen
sind wie stark die physischen
Auswirkungen sind und darunter verstehen
wir natürlich so etwas wie die Zunahme
von Angst die Zunahme von Depressionen
die Zunahme von
Einsamkeitsgefühlen die Zunahme auch von
Gewicht beispielsweise für Kinder das
ist international sehr gut belegt auch
wenn wir auch hier darauf hinzuweisen
haben es ist nicht nur die
Schulschließung als solches sondern dass
das Miteinander des ganzen Geschlechts
von Maßnahmen und wir können im Moment
nicht sagen es ist dieses was kausal
dazu beiträgt
es gibt natürlich auch kognitive Folgen
wie ist eigentlich der Lernerfolg wie
ist der Lernfortschritt wir wissen aus
Studien mittlerweile dass Kinder die
leistungsstärker sind auch in Zeiten von
Schulschließungen viel mehr Zeit zu
Hause verwendet haben auch die besseren
Materialien hatten auf die besseren
digitalen Endgeräte hatten als Kinder
die lernen schwächer waren und
wesentlich weniger Zeit aufgebracht
haben das ist eine unbekannte Studie des
ifo Instituts die wir hier rezipieren
wir haben aber für Deutschland noch
keine Daten die zeigen wie lang anhalten
beispielsweise
kompetenzverluste sind ob sie wieder
wettgemacht werden können über die Zeit
und ob sie das können hängt natürlich
auf und unseren intervenierenden
Variablen ab also davon ob wir jetzt
gerade mit den betroffenen Schülerinnen
und Schüler mit den lernschwächeren
Kindern die auch noch aus niedrigen
sozialökonomischen Schichten kommen uns
besonders beschäftigt nun alles
daransetzen diese Schulschließungen und
viele dieser digitalen Unterrichtsformen
nachträglich so gut ist irgendwie geht
zu kompensieren was ist also
diesbezüglich zu tun wir brauchen auf
alle Fälle hier eine viel größere
individuelle Erreichbarkeit die kann
auch digital sein wir brauchen digital
Coaches die die Kinder da ranführen in
Hilfe an die Hand geben und nicht nur
den Kindern sondern natürlich auch ihren
Eltern wir brauchen aber auch und das
steht sehr deutlich darin so etwas wie
ein Rechtsanspruch auf ein Mindestmaß an
sozialen Kontakten der ja auch oft
verloren gegangen ist auch und gerade zu
nahen Bezugspersonen wir müssen hier
einfach auch zu ungewöhnlichen Maßnahmen
greifen mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer
dass wir hier
Abschlussklausuren im größten Ballsaal
Berlins durchgeführt haben man hätte mit
den Schulklassen auch in Museen gehen
können in Kirchen gehen können wo wir
mehr Platz gehabt hätten also was wäre
ein thinking out of the box und das
halten wir für absolut notwendig
wenn ich auf die Gesellschaft jetzt
eingehe dann haben wir zwei Bereiche
untergliedert einmal der ganz besonders
betroffene Bereich von Eltern mit
kleinen Kindern und hier nochmal genauer
von Müttern kleine Kinder die da die
Kinder keine Infrastruktur mehr hatten
die Kitas waren oft zu oder waren was
die Quarantäne dann der Kinder betrifft
nicht zuverlässig offen weil die Kinder
zu Hause bleiben mussten bei den Schulen
ist es ebenso und wir sehen bei Müttern
in der Tat ein ganzes Bündel von
negativen Auswirkungen die Zufriedenheit
tritt dramatisch nach unten es reduziert
sich die
Arbeitszeit die bezahlte Arbeitszeit wo
hingegend die gezahlt die gesamte Arbeit
nach oben geht einfach weil die
unbezahlte Betreuungszeit so viel
stärker nach oben gehen wir sehen ein
Rückfall in alte Geschlechterrollen
welches sie als retraditionalisierung
gezeichnet habe und wir sehen ein
unglaubliches Ausmaß an mentale
Erschöpfung auch hier sind wir sehr klar
in dem was wir zu tun haben wir brauchen
zielgruppenspezifische Ansprache wir
brauchen eine Entlastung von
insbesondere jungen Eltern und wir
können das Einrichten das haben andere
Länder zum Teil auch vorgemacht die
zweite große Gruppe über die wir
sprechen ist nicht minder wichtig das
sind die sogenannten vulnerablen Gruppen
also Arbeitsmigranten Personen die armen
sind in Armut leben oder von Armut
gefährdet sind und die müssen wir viel
mehr erreichen weil wir schon während
der Pandemie sehen was wir jetzt noch
verstärkt durch die Inflation sehen und
durch den Krieg und den energienotstand
dass die Schere aufgeht zwischen jenen
die sich irgendwie behelfen können die
Kontakte haben und jenen die sich eben
nicht behelfen können und unsere Hilfe
brauchen und auch das können sie
entsprechend nachlesen der dritte ist
dann die Wirtschaft und das macht Herr
Schmidt
ja sehr gerne das mache ich auch ganz
schnell es gibt ja einschlägige Arbeiten
des Sachverständigenrats der
wissenschaftlichen Beiräte von
finanzwirtschaftsministerium der
Gemeinschaftsdiagnose und anderen in der
in der Essenz ist es klar die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft ist so in die
internationale Arbeitsteilung
eingebunden wie kaum eine andere
Volkswirtschaft ist eine globale Krise
die deutsche Volkswirtschaft ist also
davon sehr stark betroffen war von
vornherein klar dass sie sehr stark
betroffen ist oder sein wird die
deutsche Wirtschaft befand sich vor dem
Eintritt in diese Krise bereits am Ende
eines langen Aufschwungs war so ein
unglücklicher Zeitpunkt die Industrie
war bereits in einer Schwächephase und
in einer solchen Situation schlägt eine
Pandemie die Belastung durch eine
Pandemie entweder direkt zu
beispielsweise durch Arbeitsausfälle
oder aber durch die Abwendung zu der
Abwendung der gesundheitlichen Folgen
ergriffenen Maßnahmen das ist sehr
schwer auseinander zu halten denn man
muss immer fragen was wäre denn bei
einem anderen Eingreifen der Politik bei
einer geringeren das Intensität was
wären die kompensierenden
Ausweichbewegungen der
Wirtschaftsakteure gewesen selbst die
Frage zu stellen was uns Corona in
Anführungsstrichen insgesamt gekostet
hat ist schwer denn sie müssen so was
wie eine kontrafaktische
Konjunkturprognose gegen den
tatsächlichen Verlauf halten Schätzungen
gehen dahin dass das ein dreistelliger
Milliardenbetrag ist der es in den zwei
Jahren Corona 2020 2021 verloren
gegangen ist eine ganz besondere Krise
weil sie sowohl auf der Angebots als auf
der Nachfrageseite
wirkt
Beschäftigte fallen auslieferketten
werden unterbrochen bei der
Nachfrageseite man hat sehr stark von
physischen Kontakt auf Versandhandel
seinen konsumen Nachfrage umgestellt und
so weiter was ist an einer solchen Krise
ohne staatliches Eingreifen wohl zu
erwarten nun es gibt sehr viel Evidenz
dafür dass in einer Krise in der einfach
ein Detail der Wirtschaft lahmgelegt
wird massive Beschäftigungsverluste
typischerweise drohen eine Einbruch der
verfügbaren Einkommen Anstieg der
Unternehmensinsolvenzen und
Zusammenbruch wirtschaftliche Existenzen
dazu ist es nicht in dem Ausmaß gekommen
den man am Anfang befürchten musste das
hat vermutlich haben keinerlei Evidenz
dagegen hat vermutlich sehr viel damit
zu tun wie Bund und Länder intensiv und
rasch eingegriffen haben gestützt durch
eine Haushaltspolitik die Spielräume
eröffnet hatte davor mit
kurzarbeitsregelungsausweitung
überbrückungsleistungen und ähnlichem
die kontrafaktische Frage wie wäre es
denn gewesen ohne dieses Maßnahmenbündel
ist genauso wenig systematisch gestellt
worden wie im Gesundheitsbereich aber
wir haben auch keinerlei Anlass zu
vermuten dass ohne staatliche Eingriffe
wenn der Staat sich komplett
zurückgehalten hätte alles so glimpflich
abgelaufen wäre wie wir es jetzt gesehen
haben von daher haben wir grosso-modo
die
wirtschaftspolitischen Maßnahmen als
zumindest einen Beitrag zum gedämpften
Verlauf eingeordnet
wir schalten jetzt zu Frau Kießling für
den letzten Teil des Statements ja ich
grüße Sie herzlich aus Frankfurt ich
kann leider heute nicht vor Ort dabei
sein
aber da werde ich jetzt den rechtlichen
Teil der juristischen Teil
zusammenfassen vorab wir haben nicht das
ganze Infektionsschutzgesetz evaluiert
das war auch gar nicht der Auftrag aber
manchmal muss man das so ein bisschen in
die Perspektive Rücken
desinfektionsschutzgesetz hat ungefähr
80 Paragraphen und wir haben jetzt einen
kleinen Teil davon haben wir uns
angeschaut das waren die Vorschriften
die man in der corona-epidemie neu
geschaffen hat oder geändert hat um sie
dann sozusagen für die Pandemie noch
besonders anwendbar zu machen diese
Vorschriften wurden sehr häufig geändert
in der Epidemie also in den letzten zwei
Jahren und sie wurden auch in unserem
evaluationszeitraum dreimal geändert
also einmal im November einmal im
Dezember und dann im März und was wir
nicht gemacht haben ist wir haben nicht
diese drei unterschiedlichen oder
eigentlich dann vier unterschiedlichen
Gesetzeslagen ganz kleinteilig
analysiert sondern wir haben uns eher
auf die größeren Fragen konzentriert
also auch so konzeptionfragen wie sollte
man überhaupt die jeweiligen
Vorschriften zuschneiden wie sollte man
sie
zukunftsfest machen was müsste man also
dort Regeln damit das längeren Bestand
hat im Moment werden Sie immer aktuell
nur auf wenige Monate befristet
jedenfalls einiges Paragraphen und vorab
deswegen zwei Empfehlungen von uns wir
empfehlen einmal diese
corona-spezifischen Regelungen doch so
zu konzipieren dass sie eben nicht nur
auf Corona zugeschnitten sind sondern
dass sie für alle Krankheitserreger Geld
hätten die Krankheitserreger
unterscheiden sich ja in ihrer
Übertragungsart und auch in der Art der
Krankheit die sie hervorrufen und man
kann aber Regelung schaffen das haben
wir in sonstige Infektionsschutzgesetz
also in den anderen Vorschriften auch
die das etwas allgemeiner angehen geben
und es nicht nur für einen einzelnen
Krankheitserreger besonders regeln wir
empfehlen auch dass man den Rechtsrahmen
nicht mehr so häufig ändert wie das in
den letzten zwei Jahren passiert ist
also dass man nicht wenn sich die
infektionslage wesentlich ändert sofort
wieder Gesetz die Maßnahmen ganz neu
dort zulässt oder eben aus dem Katalog
herausschreibt sondern dass man
Regelungen macht die dann auch erstmal
gelten nur angepasst werden wenn man
wirklich da
besonderen Anpassungsbedarf sieht man
kann das Gesetz so fassen dass es eben
auch Änderungen der infektionslage dann
also das ist möglich ist das dann zu
berücksichtigen wenn das Gesetz
angewendet wird das Gesetz hat nur in
einem einzigen Punkt also nur bei einer
Vorschrift das ist der 28b wurden werden
unmittelbar durch das Gesetz Maßnahmen
schon festgelegt ansonsten müssen die
Länder das Gesetz ja ausführen und dann
eben dann an den Einzelfall anpassen
ja dann würde ich gerne noch etwas zu
Feststellung der epidemischen Lage von
nationaler Tragfläche sagen weil das ein
Konstrukt ist was in der Epidemie erst
geschaffen wurde also im Frühling 2020
das hatten wir bis dahin nicht im
Infektionsschutzgesetz das ist eine
Feststellung die der Bundestag trifft
also er passt ein Beschluss und dieser
Beschluss wiederum hat dann
unterschiedliche Rechtsfolgen und das
muss man auch unterscheiden was er dann
oder wozu er dann jeweils führt also
unmittelbar so hat er selber noch keine
Auswirkungen aber er
das dann dass man andere Vorschriften
anwendet die man eben nicht durch ohne
diesen feststellungsbeschluss anwenden
könnte und da haben wir einmal das was
im Paragrafen 5 wo auch dieser
Feststellung geregelt ist wo das auch
noch im gleichen Paragrafen geregelt ist
da wird das Bundesgesundheitsministerium
ermächtigt von vielen verschiedenen
anderen Gesetzen also von anderen
Fachgesetzen abzuweichen durch
Verordnung und da wird gar nicht klar
und wissen welche Fachgesetze das sein
können sondern es wird nur sehr hoch
Umrissen welche Bereiche das betrifft
zum Beispiel die Versorgung mit
Arzneimitteln oder die sonstige
gesundheitliche Versorgung und da ist
der Umfang dieser Ermächtigung gar nicht
richtig klar weil man eben gar nicht
weiß von welchem Gesetz man abweichen
darf und diese Konstruktion wurde schon
sehr früh auch an der Rechtswissenschaft
als verfassungswidrig eingestuft da der
Einschätzung schließen wir uns auch an
was nicht heißt dass man nicht ganz
grundsätzlich diese Dinge regeln kann
aber wir empfehlen dass man sie dann
eben in den jeweiligen Fachgesetzen also
dort wo ihr abgewichen werden soll dass
man dort solche Ermächtigungen schafft
und das nicht im Infekt so breit regelt
und dann haben wir ja die zentrale
Vorschrift des 28a der die ganzen
Schutzmaßnahmen regelt die er dann durch
die Länder ergriffen werden und der war
auch lange Zeit an die Feststellung
durch die Bundestag gekommen diese
Regelung haben wir auch nach wie vor die
wurde im November also gar nicht aus dem
Gesetz gestrichen sie steht immer noch
drin auch wenn wir jetzt dort auch
weitere Möglichkeiten haben dass man
ohne den Beschluss Maßnahmen ergreift
aber da empfehlen wir auch dass man das
ganz grundsätzlich also dass man nicht
an diesen feststellungsbeschluss
anknüpft sondern dass man ihn ganz
weglässt und dass man Regelungen schafft
das wäre jetzt auch eine wichtige
Empfehlung dass man aus differenzierte
Regelung schafft aktuell haben wir
wirklich eine Paragraphen für ungefähr
20 verschiedene Schutzmaßnahmen dass man
da das in mehreren Vorschriften regelt
und sich anschaut welche Lebensbereiche
sind betroffen die unterscheiden sich ja
zum Teil erheblich welche Grundrechte
sind dann auch dort betroffen eben weil
es unterschiedliche Lebensbereiche und
unterschiedliche Personengruppen die
betroffen sind und dass man dann auf
dieser Grundlage
klein differenzierte Vorschriften
schafft die dann eben die jeweiligen
Voraussetzungen in der Vorschrift selber
regeln also wann dürfen die Länder dann
welche Maßnahmen ergreifen also da kann
man eben durch
eingriffschwellen wenn wir das dann im
Recht kann man dann genau regeln Band
die Länder die ergreifen dürfen das sind
eben nicht irgendwelche Blanco
mächtigungen und deswegen empfehlen wir
wie gesagt dass man am Vorschriften
schreibt die für alle Krankheitserreger
gelten und die dann sehr
ausdifferenziert genau regeln was die
Länder in welcher Situation bei welchen
Erreger sozusagen machen dürfen vielen
Dank
ja vielen Dank an die
Kommissionsmitglieder für die Statements
wir kommen nun zum Frageteil jetzt
möchte ich noch mal die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Online zugeschaltet ist
darauf hinweisen wie wir das machen sie
melden bitte Fragen an nur per
elektronischem Handzeichen also bitte
keine Fragen in den Chat schreiben sie
können den Chat nutzen für technische
Fragen da hilft Ihnen dann das Backends
aber fragen bitte nur per elektronisches
Handzeichen wir beginnen aber mit Fragen
aus dem Saal bitte Handzeichen ich habe
jetzt zunächst Frau Bader von der ARD
ja ich hätte zwei Fragen wenn Sie
gestatten sie verweisen auf die
schlechte Datenlage und auf andere
Länder wo das besser läuft können Sie da
ein paar konkrete Beispiele nennen und
was wir uns da ganz konkret abschauen
müssen und wenn ich richtig verstanden
habe sagen sie aber auch nicht dass
irgendeine Maßnahme diese begutachten
haben gar nichts gebracht hat
also die erste Frage glaube ich geht an
Herrn Schmidt ja ich würde es mal so
zusammenfassen diejenigen Länder die im
Bereich public health aktiver sind wie
beispielsweise die USA des UK sind uns
da voraus in der Schweiz gab es eine
Evaluationskommission also wir haben
natürlich jetzt keinen internationalen
Vergleich angestrengt der irgendwie
Noten verteilt hätte für das tun in
anderen Ländern aber es ist ganz klar
wir können aus der eigenen Vergangenheit
lernen erstens von den anderen lernen
pragmatisch public health Forschung mehr
in den Mittelpunkt zu rücken wäre ohne
ihn an der separat in Deutschland und
wir können von der Vergangenheit aus
anderen Bereichen lernen also
insbesondere habe ich relativ viel
Erfahrung einbringen dürfen in die in
die kommissionsdiskussionen aus dem aus
der groß angelegten Evaluierung der
Agenda 2010 respektive der harzreformen
es gab schon mal eine ein Verständnis
das Wissenschaft und Politik eng
miteinander von Anfang an an der
Richtung großer Maßnahmenpakete arbeiten
müssen dass das ohne dieses
Zusammenspiel nicht geht als muss man
anfangs ein Konzept erstellen das
pragmatisch genug ist einzelne Maßnahmen
isoliert zu betrachten und das ganze
Bündel ebenfalls da muss man
insbesondere auf der kleinen räumigen
Ebene oder auf der regionalen Ebene
Datenerhebungen Hintergrund Erhebung
vollziehen und insbesondere ist es
wichtig die amtlichen Daten die
Meldedaten die ja zur Verfügung stehen
punktuell zu ergänzen um das
randomisierte Experiment dass man gerne
im Labor durchführen würde aber das darf
keinen Fall im Labor geht es geht ja um
viel größer angelegte Zusammenhänge dass
man dieses randomisierte Experiment
ersetzt mit guter datenunterfütterung da
können wir glaube ich sehr viel aus
verschiedenen Bereichen lernen wir
müssen das nur aufgreifen
möchte ergänzen ganz konkret was sie
gefragt haben was wir nicht haben ist so
etwas wie eine repräsentative
Zufallsstichprobe ja so dass wir nicht
nur die Inzidenzen also aufgrund von
Tests oder was haben sondern dass wir
wirklich deutschlandweit eine
repräsentative Zufallsstichprobe haben
die wir leider im Moment nicht haben und
das wir so etwas haben wie digitale
Patientenakten daraufhin hat schon
hingewiesen zweite Frage geht an Herrn
streek ja also wenn Sie das so direkt
fragen jede Maßnahme hat ihre Zeit und
wir gerade wenn wir weniger Infektionen
zum Beispiel am Anfang haben dann kann
können lockdowns oder ähnliche Maßnahmen
einen Effekt haben oder auch helfen das
Gesundheitswesen zu schützen dass wir
uns erstmal darauf vorbereiten genauso
Kontaktpersonen Nachverfolgung was sie
jedem ausgelassen hatte ist ein sehr
scharfes Schwert im Öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst vor allem bei
offenporten kann es dazu führen dass wir
die affenbrocken kontrollieren könnten
aber wenn wir zu hoher Infektionen haben
dann wirken solche Maßnahmen eben auch
nicht mehr also man muss das glaube ich
differenziert sehen zu welchem Zeitpunkt
zu welchem Maßnahme wirken kann und
nicht wirken kann und es kommt eben sehr
darauf an das ist vielleicht eben ein
bisschen runtergefallen dass der Mensch
auch mitmachen will und bei einem
Lockdown ist es in der Frühphase der
Fall wir haben in vielen Studien gesehen
dass es danach die die government
effectiften ist dann abfällt und meinen
Masken ist es genauso auch so in der
Frühphase wirken die besser als in der
Spätphase wenn die Leute einfach
Menschen keinen keine Lust mehr haben
Massen zu tragen
als nächstes auf der Liste habe ich Frau
Spiekermann vom ZDF bitte
das Gutachten ist ja hoch umstritten ich
wollte jetzt auch noch mal nach der
Datengrundlage fragen was entgegnen sind
Sie jetzt den Kritikern die sagen es
gibt nicht entsprechende Datengrundlage
und sie ziehen Schlüssel also das ist ja
ein relativ heikles Thema
die nächste Frage wäre von Sieger
Professor strek es wurde immer gesagt
sie seien ein Mann der FDP sie würden
die Maßnahmen im Sinne der Liberalen
interpretieren was sagen sie dazu und
vielleicht noch die dritte Frage die
Gesundheitsminister wollen ja heute
Maßnahmen beschließen
ungefähr ein paar Stunden und nachdem
wir Bericht raus ist wie bewerben sie
das
ja also drei Fragen auf einmal die erste
Frage war zu der Datengrundlage wer
möchte Herr Schmidt ja ich glaube wir
machen das ziemlich klar in unserem
methodischen aufriss und nachher auch im
bei der Bewertung der einzelnen
Maßnahmen dass wir hinreichend
pragmatisch unsere Aufgabe sehen
hinreichend pragmatisch zu sein um mit
einer imperfekten Datenlage umzugehen
wir wünschen uns eine bessere Datenlage
wenn sie nicht da ist können wir dann
guten Gewissens einfach die Antwort
verweigern nein aber wir müssen sie
einordnen und Herr Strick hat in seinem
eingangstatement ja das Wort Evidenzgrad
benutzt also manche Dinge sind
belastbarer als andere und in der mit
dem richtigen Verständnis und der
richtigen Einbettung kann man auch aus
Korrelationen schon einiges lernen man
muss sich darüber aber im Klaren sein
dass dann im Endeffekt noch nicht
wirklich der der endgültige Schluss
gezogen werden kann dass man daran noch
arbeiten muss aber gar nichts zu sagen
wäre noch viel schlechter
sie möchten ergänzen bitte ganz kurz
weil wir noch Fragen haben ich möchte
noch mal hinzufügen man muss sich auch
darüber im Klaren sein was schon
mehrfach angesprochen wurde dass die
Pandemie sicher entwickelt und
unterschiedliche Phasen hat und dass die
eine Maßnahme in der einen Phase eben
nicht optimal ist in einer anderen Phase
wir haben heute andere Möglichkeiten wir
haben Impfstoffe wir haben Medikamente
und das eine andere Lage auch bezüglich
der Maßnahmen die wir jetzt vor in dem
Zeitraum von zwei Jahren betrachtet
haben
also
ich möchte ganz kurz was sagen weil
erstreck kann ja dann selbst was sagen
zu der FDP aber wir haben hier auch wenn
wir von unterschiedlichen Parteien
vorgeschlagen worden sind mit Sicherheit
keine Kommission gehabt wo ich eine
SPD-Politik gegenüber einer fdp-politik
oder sonst gewerbten uns unterhalten
über die
evidenzbasierterung der Maßnahmen und
was wir daraus ableiten können das war
unser Ding und nicht jetzt ein oder der
anderen Partei ist gut zu machen ja
jetzt würde ich einen Strick bitten die
zweite Frage zu beantworten
die hat eigentlich Frau einem Dinger
gerade genauso beantwortet wie sehr
beantworten wurde also ist es nicht so
dass Herr Drosten eine CDU-Politik
verfolgt weil er von der CDU eingesetzt
wurde und ich eine fdp-politik verfolge
weil ich durch die FDP vorgeschlagen
wurde dass das einfach eine Frage die
die überhaupt nicht passend ist in
meinen Augen die letzte Frage ging um
das um die Dynamik um den Bericht herum
und den entschlussfolgerungen wer möchte
dazu antworten da finde ich dass sie uns
nicht dass wir nicht diejenigen sind die
sie zu fragen haben da fragten sie bitte
die entsprechenden Personen die jetzt
die Politiken ausarbeiten heute
Nachmittag
gut ich gehe weiter hier vierte Reihe
wenn sie ihren Namen bitte nennen
könnten sie sind von der Bild-Zeitung
sehe ich
guten tagwegs von der BILD Frau
almendinger sie kennen die deutschen wie
kaum jemand anderer würden Sie sagen
dass es für die Akzeptanz der Maßnahmen
wie auch immer sie dann diesen Herbst
aussehen werden gut wäre wenn sich jetzt
jemand entschuldigt oder ist es völlig
egal
entschuldigt in dem Sinne dass wir schon
in die Kameras in diesem Falle sagen
sollten dass wir es besser machen können
als wir es in den letzten zwei Jahren
gemacht haben und warum mir es besser
machen können aber insbesondere wie wir
es besser machen und dass wir es auch
besser machen
so und während die Frage Runde
weitergeht werden wir das ganze jetzt
aber mal hier für euch einordnen
analysieren ihr könnt natürlich bei uns
jetzt eure Fragen stellen denn darum
soll es jetzt gehen um eure Fragen dafür
ist der Traum und Zeit ich fasse noch
mal kurz zusammen vielleicht auch für
alle die später erst eingeschaltet haben
das waren die Sachverständigen die sich
also zusammengesetzt hatten um die
corona-maßnahmen zu bewerten und wir
haben gerade das Ergebnis gehört ich
würde mal sagen zusammenfassend kann man
sagen manche Maßnahmen also sie haben
die Maßnahmen teilweise als wirksam
bewertet wir wollen mal aufdröseln warum
das so war das war nämlich sehr
interessant da steckte viel drin denn
was wir auch gehört haben war dass sie
ganz ganz vieles gar nicht bewertet
bewerten konnten oder bewertet haben und
warum das so ist und was ich daraus
ableitet darüber können wir jetzt
sprechen mit meiner Kollegin mit der
Hauptstadtstudio Korrespondentin Andrea
Maurer die natürlich auch mit zugehört
hat Andrea schauen wir mal drauf was
fandest du denn war hier das
interessanteste für dich in diesem
ganzen Wurst von dem eben ja auch viel
Zeit darauf ging zu erfahren warum
manches nicht bewertet wurde
ja für mich war interessant dass die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
eben noch mal darauf verwiesen haben
dass sie im Grunde genommen jetzt hier
kein schlechtes Zeugnis ausgestellt
haben also nicht über die Politik
geurteilt haben das hat natürlich auch
was zu tun mit dem Erwartungsdruck unter
dem dieses Gremium das ja von der
Politik berufen wurde steht tatsächlich
ist es aber so man kann es nicht anders
sagen also Sie haben ja auf Maßnahmen
geschaut die in den letzten Jahren zwei
Jahren der Pandemie von der Politik
erlassen wurden und es ist eben ein
gemischtes Urteil sie sagen ja auch an
vielen Stellen dass sie es nicht
bewerten können was für mich allerdings
zurückbleibt ist dass sozusagen diese
ganzen psychosozialen Folgen dass das
was sie versucht haben in Korrelation zu
setzen also eine staatlich erlassene
Maßnahme zu der Wirkung die sie
gesellschaftlich hatte dass das
eindeutig mehr in den Fokus rücken muss
dass sie sehr
deutlich auch die fehlende
Datengrundlage bemängelt haben und das
geht natürlich auch in Richtung
beispielsweise RKI also der Behörde die
dem Gesundheitsministerium untergeordnet
ist die natürlich solche studienlagen zu
verantworten hat die anscheinend einfach
im Laufe dieser Pandemie nicht eindeutig
existieren was ich auch noch
bemerkenswert fand ist sozusagen die
rechtliche Einordnung also das ist ein
sehr deutlichen Appell der Expertin der
Experten gibt dass Deutschland eine
andere Rechtsgrundlage braucht als
beispielsweise diese epidemische Lage
das ist eine Rechtsgrundlage braucht die
eben nicht erneuert werden muss oder
immer wieder zu Disposition steht
sondern dass wir eine sehr ausgefeilte
Rechtsgrundlage brauchen die auch für
zukünftige Pandemien wirksam sein kann
das sind sozusagen die Punkte die ich
jetzt aus dieser Pressekonferenz und aus
diesem Bericht erstmal für mich eben
mitgenommen habe
ich Dröse jetzt auch noch mal ganz knapp
ein bisschen auseinander und spreche
vielleicht mal die wichtigsten Punkte an
wozu auch Aussagen gemacht wurden oder
eben keine also jetzt zum Beispiel im
puncto auf die Maßnahme Kontakt
Beschränkungen da hieß es die
kontaktverfolgung sei in der Frühphase
der Pandemie wirksam gewesen so die
Sachverständigen wenn wir auf das Thema
zwei und dreijährigen zu sprechen kommen
das hat uns ja auch alle lange
beschäftigt da war die Aussage dass sie
vor allem in den ersten drei Monaten
nach der booster-impfung oder der
Genesung wirksam sein dann haben wir das
Thema gehabt Kontakt Nachverfolgung da
hieß es auch besonders effektiv zu
Pandemie beginnen Masken in Innenräumen
sinnvoll wenn korrekt getragen das war
auch noch mal ein wichtiger Zusatz wo
zum Beispiel nichts dazu gesagt wurde
war die Wirksamkeit von
Schulschließungen auch ein Thema was
viele natürlich in den letzten zwei
Jahren total aufgerieben hat Andrea wie
kann man denn das jetzt einschätzen dass
so ein Bericht in dem natürlich auch
noch so vieles unklar bleibt
wie viel ja sage ich mal wie viel wie
viel Auswirkungen kann der denn haben
also was was folgt da jetzt raus was für
eine Konsequenz das sollte ja eigentlich
eine Handlungsanweisung für den Herbst
für die Politik sein ja ganz
grundsätzlich ist es ja so das
Wissenschaft die Dinge natürlich viel
differenzierter betrachtet als es jetzt
beispielsweise Politik tut weil Politik
ja versucht klarere Zielsetzungen
Maßnahmen und so weiter im Blick zu
haben und Wissenschaft hat ja eine ganz
andere Herangehensweise an diese Dinge
was allerdings tatsächlich finde ich
doch relativ konkret ist ist das nach
Einschätzung dieser Sachverständigen die
unterschiedlichen Phasen der Pandemie
eben unterschiedlich zu bewerten sind
das heißt es wurde ja auch gesagt ein
Lockdown der am Anfang große Wirkung hat
verliert seine Wirkung weil einfach
Menschen nicht über eine große Zeit sich
in einem Lockdown
sozusagen
zurechtfinden und das ist im Grunde
genommen auch diesen Appell gibt eben zu
beachten dass Menschen mitmachen müssen
das ist natürlich eine deutliche
Aufforderung an eine gute Kommunikation
an einen Augenmaß von Maßnahmen und das
heißt auch wenn jetzt diese
Sachverständigen nicht mit deutlichen
Handlungsanweisungen an die Politik hier
heute aufgetreten sind lässt sich doch
zwischen den Zeilen zum einen Kritik
lesen aber natürlich auch sagen sie ja
auch für die Zukunft eben Dinge die
besser gemacht werden können und ich
glaube das ist schon ein Gewissen Gewinn
hat was da heute vorgestellt wurde weil
es einfach eine natürlich keine evidente
Datengrundlage gibt aber das wurde ja
eben mehrfach gesagt dass man
pragmatisch aus der Perspektive dieser
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
eben doch Rückschlüsse ziehen kann was
diese Maßnahmen betrifft noch kurz zu
den Schulschließungen da ist es eben so
das wurde ja auch gesagt dass diese
Maßnahmen Bündel also Schüler die
gleichzeitig Maske getragen haben wo
gelüftet wurde und die getestet wurde es
ist einfach nicht sozusagen
zu bewerten ob dann die Schulschließung
allein eben einen Effekt hatte und das
finde ich schon eben auch bemerkenswert
weil gleichzeitig eben darauf verwiesen
wurde wie gravierend eben die Folgen
auch für für Kinder eben waren im Zuge
dieser Schulschließung und das immerhin
weil jetzt auch eine Diskussion in den
letzten Tagen Wochen in der Politik das
im Grunde genommen das Ziel zumindest
ist Schulschließungen für diesen corona-
danke Andrea Maurer bis hierhin an
dieser Stelle vielen Dank für die
Einordnung und wir können jetzt eben in
dieser Sendung noch weiter sprechen mit
jemanden der Mitglied das
Sachverständigenausschuss war mit Klaus
Stöhr aber erstmal danke Andrea Maurer
und jetzt ist Klaus Stöhr bei uns
Epidemiologe und sie sind also auch
Mitglied dieses
Sachverständigenausschuss gewesen und
erstmal schön dass Sie bei uns sind
hallo
sehr gerne schönen guten Tag es gibt
eine Fußnote in dem Bericht in diesem
heißt es dass sie nicht mit das mit
ihnen nicht in allen Punkten Konsens
erzielt werden konnte das steht also am
Ende dieses sehr sehr langen Berichtes
sie waren ja aber Mitglied auch das
Ausschusses wieso konnte man mit ihnen
jetzt ausgerechnet keinen Content
erzählen was ist los
ja ich wünsche euch einer der wenigen
der eben sowohl eine Profession Biologie
hat also Epidemiologie als studiert hat
und auch noch aktienologie 15 Jahre
Industrie gearbeitet hat und aus diesem
Blickwinkel heraus hätte ich mir auch
als angewandter solchen Experte hätte
ich mir gewünscht dass mehr konkrete
Aussagen getroffen worden wären wir
haben ja gerade über die Schulschließung
gesprochen das ist der Punkt wo ich
glaube man hätte auch hier etwas
prägnanter formulieren können es gibt
genügend Daten aus Deutschland die auch
zeigen zum Beispiel dass die Infektion
also Ausbrüche in Schulen relativ selten
sind dass wenn solche Einzelfälle
Auftreten in weniger als 18 Prozent der
Fällen also nur ein fünft auch
tatsächlich ein zweites oder drittes
Kind betroffen sind und da kann man
schon eine ganze Menge Schlussfolgerung
daraus ziehen und man hat auch gesehen
dass zum Beispiel Erzieher Erwachsene
häufiger die Kinder infizieren als
umgekehrt
das wären für mich eigentlich schon
fundamentale schlussfolgung gewesen
sozusagen Schulschließung bringen nicht
das Ergebnis was man sich wünscht
nämlich dass man verhindert dass die
Kinder wohl neurable anstecken oder
selbst schwer krank werden man hat auch
nicht diese beiden Parameter verwendet
also bei der Bewertung Schulschließung
notwendig sind und nicht nämlich sind
die Bären die Kinder selber krank schwer
oder
infizieren sie häufig wohl Narben
sondern man hat gesagt wenn Kinder hohe
Infektiosität haben dann müssen die
Schulen geschlossen werden also das
konnte ich schon nicht mittragen weil
das für mich aus der praktischen
Bekämpfung nicht pragmatisch genug ist
weil es auch die Daten nicht reflektiert
und das sind ja Informationen die schon
seit vielen vielen Monaten vorliegen
aber Herr Stöhr wir haben jetzt gerade
eben auch von ihren Kollegen und
Kolleginnen den Sachverständigen gehört
das ist da eben auch vor allem an Zeit
gefehlt hat vor allem hatte es auch ich
zitiere an einer repräsentativen
Zufallsstichprobe für vieles gefehlt und
eine Sache möchte ich auch noch ergänzen
das ist auch interessant sie sind
nachgerückt für Christian Drosten den
bekannten Virologen der ausgetreten ist
der quasi ja nicht mehr Teil dann in
dieser Sachverständigen war weil er eben
es sagte oder es so sah dass er sagte es
ist eben schwierig methodisch sauber das
ganze in so kurzer Zeit von einem
ehrenamtlichen Gremium bewerten zu
lassen in diesen wenigen Monaten also da
sagten schon auch eben viele dass das
einfach schwierig sei in dieser kurzen
Zeit auf wirklich wissenschaftliche
Erkenntnisse stichhaltige Ergebnisse zu
kommen sehen Sie das so ganz anders als
die anderen
überhaupt nicht ich teile ja die
Blickwinkel der Kollegen die den dieser
Kommission hat man ja schon ein Problem
in die Geburtsurkunde geschrieben
nämlich dass man die erste eingesetzt
hat als die zwei Drittel der Pandemie
schon vorbei waren dann hat man auch in
Deutschland vergessen das ist auch sehr
gut beschrieben worden in dem Dokument
dass ein Forschungskonzept hätte
aufgesetzt werden müssen solche
Maßnahmen beginnt dann hat man keine
komplette Datenlage da kann man nicht
sagen wie gut wirken
kontaktbeschränkungen wie gut wir
Quarantäne werde alles getestet werden
wirken jetzt die Ausgangssperre und das
kann man nicht sagen aber wenn man
solche Maßnahmen ergreift ist es nicht
nur gute Praxis sondern auch zwingend
notwendig für das Krisenmanagement
begleitende Forschung aufzusetzen oder
3-4 Monaten sagen kann ja haben die
Maßnahmen gewirkt oder nicht sind die
vielleicht sogar kontraproduktiv das
fehlt ja alles und das hat natürlich die
Arbeit der Kommission nicht erleichtert
dazu kommt natürlich noch dass die
dass die Zusammensetzung des Teams
weniger vielleicht die die praktische
solchen Bekämpfung berücksichtigt
laborvirologen helfen da nicht viel da
brauchen also krankenhaushygieniker da
braucht man angewandte Epidemiologen die
die eigene Erfahrung gesammelt haben in
der solchen Bekämpfung da braucht man
sicherlich auch Statistiker und so
weiter das hat man alles nicht mit
hineingeschrieben das muss man also dann
da muss man damit auch leben sowohl die
Gruppe als auch die Gesellschaft und das
wurde ja gesagt aber noch mal es gibt
einige Bereiche und dazu zähle ich die
Schulschließungen erzähle ich auch die
Diskussion über die Übersterblichkeit
die in dem Papier meines Erachtens nicht
konsequent genug auch herausgearbeitet
wurde wo man hätte prägnanter sauberer
sein müssen mehr als 80 Prozent der
Diskussionen gefühlt waren ja ging es um
die Kinder die Schulschließung und nun
hat man nicht nur kein genügend Daten
das ist die Schlüssel und der Gruppe
sondern die Daten die vorliegen zum
Beispiel aus Deutschland ausrechnen und
aus Rheinland-Pfalz sind auch nicht
berücksichtigt worden wo man noch
einigermaßen sicher sagen kann wie oft
Kinder sich dann infizieren wie hoch
kosten sie aus den die Ausbrüche
tatsächlich wie oft werden solche
Infektion noch weitergereicht in der in
der in den Klassen sind Eltern oder
Kinder häufiger an die Quelle zu sehen
also die dann hätte man so formulieren
können nicht in allen Bereichen aber es
wird auf jeden Fall es sind rund 200.000
Studien zum Thema Corona auf dem Markt
also da gibt es eine ganze ganze Menge
Daten warum woran hat es gelegen hatten
sie also demnach keine Zeit alle zu
evaluieren oder wo ist die Problematik
weil es sind ja ganz viele Daten erhoben
worden
die andere Gründe warum die Kommissionen
auch nicht selbst ein Ziel gestellt hat
dass eben unter den zumindest
öffentlichen Erwartungen lag weil die
Zeit auch nicht ausreicht also etwas für
die sogenannten Cockring Studien also
Studien die sehr umfassen die
Weltliteratur analysieren die dauern
dann mindestens im Jahr und da sitzen
große Teams dahinter die dann auch nur
ein relativ kleinen Bereich analysiert
wir schauen sich mal allein die
Maßnahmen die man evaluieren wollte das
fängt ja an bei Ausgangssperren bei
grenzschließungen bei
kontaktbeschränkungen Quarantäne Testung
wie gesagt Schulschließung Lockdown oder
gibt es einen großen Spektrum also das
große Feld in dieser kurzen Zeit mit der
kleinen Gruppe und dann auch mit der
entsprechenden
beruflichen Ausstattung zu abzuackern
ist einfach möglich
mehr der Politik hätte an die Hand geben
müssen und es ist eben nicht meine
Position dass man das so formuliert das
letztendlich jeder sein Stückchen
rauslesen kann ist die Gesellschaft ist
ja eigentlich zwiegespalten es gibt die
Personen die Gruppen die sagen wir
müssen mehr machen und die anderen sagen
es reicht eigentlich aus wir sind für so
gut und für mich liest sich der Bericht
auch für den vielen Bereichen so dass
sowohl die einen als auch die anderen
ihre Position sauber vertreten können
obwohl die sagen
wir müssen mehr machen im Herbst steht
ja da drin wir haben nicht genügend
Daten aber es funktioniert ja doch und
die haben ja eine Pressekonferenz auch
gehört dass eine Frage kam glaube ich
aus ihrem Sender sogar das gefragt wurde
ja aber gibt es denn irgendeine machen
die von dem man weiß dass sie überhaupt
nicht funktioniert hat natürlich haben
alle Maßnahmen oder einen Effekt aber
das war ja nicht die Fragestellung die
Fragestellung ist die wie wirken die
macht dann wie effizient sind die
Maßnahmen sind die verhältnismäßig und
auch und die Maßnahmen unseren anderen
zu vergleichen das ist der Punkt schauen
Sie wenn man ein Eimer Wasser ins Meer
schüttet ist das Meer definitiv voller
aber es ist nicht zu merken und du kann
man auch viele der Maßnahmen vielleicht
beurteilen und hier wäre es wichtig
gewesen diese Kalibrierung durchzuführen
die Maßnahmen noch zu vergleichen dass
das schwer ist dass das immer
Maßnahmenbündel sind völlig ohne Frage
dass man das nicht bei allen Maßnahmen
machen kann völlig ohne Frage aber ich
hätte mir ein bisschen mehr bis
gewünscht aber dann lassen Sie uns doch
gerne mal ein bisschen konkreter werden
und gerade auch auf das wie schauen da
möchte ich Sie auch gerne mit einer
eigenen Aussage noch mal konfrontieren
sie sagten Masken tragen Abstand halten
aktuell eher nicht notwendig haben die
Bundesregierung für panikmodus
kritisiert und außerdem davon gesprochen
dass das unnötigerweise Infektion nach
hinten schiebe jetzt haben wir gerade
aber auch ganz klar von ihrem Kollegen
Hendrik streek gehört Masken tragen
richtig sitzen das ist wirksam würden
sie das so nicht unterschreiben
die haben zwei Dinge eben gesagt die im
ersten Satz war die Frage sind Masken
notwendig jetzt und jetzt als letztes
fahren die sind Masken wirksam das sind
zwei unterschiedliche Themen
die Masken jetzt sind aus meinem Blick
nicht notwendig warum nicht weil es
nicht verhältnismäßig wäre notwendig
wären sie dann wenn tatsächlich die als
Allgemeinwohl gefährdet werden wenn die
Intensivstation die Krankenhäuser wieder
zunehmende Belastung hätten oder sogar
Überlastung hätten dann wäre das
notwendig zu ihrer zweiten Frage wirksam
ja wirksam sind die schon da kann man
eine ganze Menge Infektionen reduzieren
man kann die
vulnerablen Schützen eine Masken werden
nicht umsonst routinemäßig im
Krankenhäusern
vom Pflegestationen getragen bei
Operationen das ist dann aber zwei
unterschiedliche Fragen und jetzt Masken
zu tragen und jetzt Abstand zu halten in
der Situation wo wir zu Ende minären und
wo im Prinzip alle auch nach impfangebot
hatten hoffentlich noch viel mehr das im
Angebot auch annehmen und man weiß
natürlich sowieso alle infizieren ist im
Sommer wo das Allgemeinwohl nicht
gefährdet ist aus meinem Blickwinkel
nicht mehr die Priorität und im Herbst
kann es gut sein dass es wieder
notwendig wird ich glaube es nicht aber
man kann es gut wieder sein dass die
wirksame Masken dann auch wieder
notwendig ich würde Ihnen gerne dazu
einen Kommentar aus unserer Community
Vorlesen denn hier können natürlich
unsere Userinnen und User auch direkt
reagieren Michael von der Wiese hinter
Hamburg so nennt er sich schreibt bei
Youtube was soll jetzt passieren in
Schleswig-Holstein hat man alles laufen
lassen und nun sind viele Schüler und
Lehrer krank falls nichts passiert gibt
es sowieso keinen Unterschied im Herbst
was antworten Sie denn
tatsächlich Schleswig-Holstein glaube
ich 1200 in Sachsen die inzidenten
glaube ich bei 20300 also die im
Fahrdienst Schleswig-Holstein viel
besser glaube ich als in Sachsen und
trotzdem sind die Intelligenzen so aber
wie schauen sie mal auf die
Intensivstationen die Krankenhäusern
jawohl es werden Kinder krank ich bin
auch
in Bayern ich habe mir zweimal jetzt
Corona geholt nach dreimaliger Impfung
jetzt werde ich langsam in die mdmi
übergehen und sogar das in allen
Bundesländern auch übrigens mit allen
Menschen in Deutschland passieren leider
mir wäre viel Virus lieber auch weg dann
würde es mir lieber sein es bleibt aber
und es wird alles finden fraglos und
deswegen ist es jetzt im Sommer
eigentlich
schwierig noch zu sagen wir wollen
jägerinfektion verhüten es geht ja auch
nicht 60 bis 90% der Personen die ins im
Krankenhaus auf Corona getestet werden
die kommen da wegen ganz anderer
Beschwerden sind sind Corona positiv
das heißt also die wissen gar nicht dass
sie ausscheiden die wissen gar nicht
dass sie also symptomatisch infiziert
sind und deswegen sind die Testung auch
jetzt nicht mehr notwendig jawohl man
wird eine Zunahme der asymptomatischen
leichten Fälle sehen aber solange wie
die Intensivstation Krankenhäuser nicht
überlaufen und ich hoffe das bleibt so
werden die Infektion auch nicht zu
verhindern sein ich möchte denjenigen
sehen der mir mal eine Antwort auf die
Frage was könnte man denn noch machen
außer jetzt einzelne Infektion verhüten
und nach hinten verschieben man schiebt
jede Infektion 0 Stückchen nach hinten
deswegen jetzt nur noch Abend unbedingt
sollten sich die Grundimmunisierung
holen und dann im Herbst noch mal ein
Buchstabe auch wenn die Krankenhäuser
nicht voll sind auch viele
Krankheitsverläufe mit milbenverlauf
belasten ja in der Summe dann auch das
System oder wie sehen Sie das
ja natürlich es gibt long Koweg das sind
keine kleine Ernte von Fällen und die
Menschen haben Schwierigkeiten Hilfe zu
finden es gibt keine nicht genügend
blond kurvezentren in Deutschland
dasselbe trifft übrigens bei den für die
Impfnebenwirkungen sind jetzt wenn ich
das richtige glaube ich über 70
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
geimpft 72 glaube ich und da gibt es
auch eine große Anzahl von
Impfnebenwirkungen die werden auch
vielleicht unterschätzt das ist ein Teil
dieser Natur dieses Naturereignis Corona
wenn wir jetzt allerdings nicht geimpft
hätten dann würden die Auswirkungen
natürlich noch viel schlimmer sein aber
helfen Sie mir wie kann man longkowitsch
verhindern wie kann man die Infektion
verändern wie kann man die komplett
wie kann man das durch die Pandemie
gehen ohne die Infektion auf die
Osterinsel fahren geht auch nicht die
haben sich auch schon alle infiziert
also mir wäre es auch lieber wenn das
Virus weggeht aber jetzt noch zu glauben
dass man die Infektion nie bekommt ist
falsch und leider kann man erst dann
normal in die Endemie gehen dann nehmen
wieder normal führen wenn man sich
mehrmals infiziert hat das ist bei allen
anderen Atemwegserkrankungen auch so und
das Influenza sind adenovieren
renovieren renovieren metaplanovieren
parametrieren alle die bekommt man als
Kind mehrmals bis zum Jugendalter und
dann ist man eigentlich dadurch
einigermaßen dann infiziert sich immer
wieder und im Alter dann gibt es ja nur
einen Impfstoff gegenwärtig gegen als
nächster kann Influenza dann kann man
sich den noch mal holen um dann diese
vulnerable Phase besser durchzustehen
mir wäre es anders auch lieber wenn es
kein longkurrypt geben würde und keine
entnehmen wird
mit Blick hier noch mal in unsere
Kommentare und Fragen sehe ich zum einen
dass wir auch recht unterschiedliche
Meinungen dazu haben zwei möchte ich
vorlesen und dann noch eine Frage an Sie
richten zum einen Philipp Kleinmann bei
Facebook schreibt die Menschen die sich
an nichts halten machen ist noch
schlimmer keine Maske kein Abstand und
die Zahlen steigen noch mehr Hans-peter
Bachmann bei Facebook schreibt
mittlerweile ist klar dass die Maßnahmen
so gut wie gar nichts gebracht haben
sondern eher kontraproduktiv waren kann
man das so ganz einfach sagen wie Herr
Bachmann das hier beschreibt
ja zur ersten Frage nochmal ja keine
Maßnahmen sind falsch weil wir müssen
die wohl noch ablen schützen da geht es
darum dass natürlich die impffahrten
erhöht hat vor allen Dingen den
stationären mobilen Altenpflege auch bei
den Pflegepersonal das hier die Kranken
dass die Hygienekonzepte umgesetzt
werden 40%
waren ja 40% der Todesfälle Kammer
dieser Gruppe der
Pflegeeinrichtung kleine Gruppe fast
eine Million Menschen also da muss man
mehr tun aber die Infektion bei den
Kindern Jugendlichen bei allen anderen
wird man nicht verhindern können die
sollte erst dann passieren wenn man
geimpft ist vor allem die wollen zur
zweiten Frage Maßnahmen haben alle nicht
gewirkt das ist Unsinn natürlich haben
die Maßnahmen waren die wichtig das
erste Mal in der Geschichte der
Pandemien konnte man einen Impfstoff
relativ schnell
in der Pandemie im großen Mengen
produziert es gab es noch niemals
Pandemien gab es aber alle ungefähr
viermal jedes Jahr 100 in den letzten
Jahrzehnten und da die Infektion nach
hinten zu verschieben also die Kontakte
zu beschränken vielleicht mit besseren
Maßnahmen besser auch terminisierten
Lockdown das war absolut notwendig dann
konnte man die Schützen die man dann
durch die Impfung auf die erzinfektion
vorbereiten konnte also gibt natürlich
wirkende Maßnahmen aber damit einige hat
man es übertrieben aus meinem
Blickwinkel die Schulschließungen die
Schweiz auch Frankreich
bene Look Zylinder die
skandinavischen Länder sind ja viel
moderierte herangegangen mit weit mit
vergleichbaren oder sogar besseren
erfolgen also das ist nur ein Beispiel
aber Maßnahmen haben was gewirkt Impfung
vor allen Dingen sicherlich auch Maske
tragen aber das ist jetzt wo die
Pandemie zum Ende geht muss man die
Maßnahmen anpassen tarieren und der
Situation entsprechend auch dann
Herunterfahren jetzt sagten eben einige
ihrer Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Sachverständigen eben gerade
interessekonferenz und eben auch im
Bericht die Schulschließungen die hätte
man nicht in voller Gänze bewerten
können beurteilen können ich glaube das
verwirrt jetzt viele Menschen da draußen
sie haben zusammengesessen Experten
Experten und das was dabei herauskommt
zeigt schon auch dass die sich da uneins
waren was sollen die Menschen zu Hause
denn jetzt eigentlich davon ableiten
wenn Sie die Expertinnen und Experten
sich da jetzt auch gerade uneins sind
ja das ist genau das was natürlich die
die Situation auch jetzt befeuert
deswegen hatte ich mir auch gewünscht
dass man hier ein bisschen konkreter
wird dass man versucht auf der
Datengrundlage wie man hat aber eben
auch dort aufzeigt wo man eben nicht
genügend Daten hat dass man aus seinem
Erfahrungsschatz schöpft und zum auch
die Kollegen zum Beispiel eine
Gesundheitsämtern war ja auch eine
Kollegin dabei aber noch stärker
einbezieht und hier pragmatische
herangeht also wenn es tatsächlich so
ist und die Daten das Hessen und
Rheinland-Pfalz sind ja nicht so
schlecht das hat die Infektion in den
Schulen Welten passiert selten dass die
Eltern und Erzieher mehr die Infektionen
in die Schulen hineinbringen dass die
Kinder sich selten untereinander
anstecken dann gibt es das schon relativ
klare Aussage der größte Ausbruch den
man in Deutschland gesehen hat in
Hamburg wurde er viel zitiert wurde
immer wieder darauf verwiesen dass eben
doch Kinder sich untereinander anstecken
ja da hat man nun herausgefunden das
Ganze unter der unter dem Radarschirm
dann publiziert wurden offensichtlich
wurde auch nicht große weiter verbreitet
wurde durch einen Lehrer eingeschleppt
oder ein Lehrer hat einen anderen Lehrer
infiziert und der hat dann die Klasse
oder Großteil dieser infizierten da
angesteckt also die Daten hätte man
konkreter herausbringen müssen für die
Politik vielleicht ist es schon so
wieder Clinton mal gesagt hat der der
ehemalige US-Präsident er möchte nur
noch einarmige Berater haben nicht mehr
zweiarmige denn der einarmige wenn die
seinen Berater haben gesagt on the
one-handys und die andere und die
Politiker können mit diesen zwei
Positionen nehmen nur schwierig umgehen
ganz klar deswegen wünsche ich mir auch
Wissenschaftler die eben noch mal den
ja die Zähne zusammenbeißen und sagen
hier und ich glaube dass du das ist
richtig und super machst
ich glaube wir zu Hause können mit so
zwei verschiedenen Positionen auch nur
schwierig umgehen wir haben noch einige
Fragen und Kommentare ich versuche sie
ein bisschen zusammenzufassen so viel
Zeit haben wir nicht mehr aber einen
finde ich auch noch besonders spannend
weil sie haben ja auch einen Unterschied
aufgemacht wenn ich sie da richtig
verstanden habe zwischen dem Sommer
jetzt gerade eben sie sagten also
Abstand halten Masken tragen gerade
nicht notwendig und dann kommt der
Herbst darauf bezieht sich Nana
schwarzfrage von Facebook sie schreibt
dort warum wird von Lauterbach schon für
den Herbst geplant wenn seit Wochen
alles egal ist überall keine Maske und
keine Tests mehr notwendig aber dann ab
Herbst wieder alles auf hundert Prozent
dann oh Wunder die Zahlen werden
plötzlich explodieren wer hätte es
gedacht haben sie die Befürchtung nicht
ja natürlich jedes Jahr ich bin nun
schon seit 30 Jahren im Geschäft jedes
Jahr gibt es einen
winterkrankungen zunehmen das ist völlig
Faktor eine Intensivstation werden hoch
belastet sein es gibt doch die Verlegung
von Patienten vielleicht von einem
regierungsbezirklichen anderen 2017/18
war eine ganz dramatische Influenza
Welle gewesen wo genau das so passiert
ist und in diesem Jahr wird das wieder
passieren wie hoch die Welle dann wird
also wie stark dann die Intensivstation
über das Normale hinaus mach hinaus
belastet werden hängt davon ab ob man es
schafft von der Bundesregierung damit
einer guten Impfkampagne die immunlücke
zu verkleinern die immune gekennt man
nicht weil man keine entsprechende
Studie finanzieren wollte das ist jetzt
zum Glück passiert
letzte Woche wissen wir dass da so eine
Studie kommen wird und wenn man die Mode
bekommt kann man die versuchen durch
eine gezielte Kampagne zu schließen und
dann versuchen das Allgemeinwohl zu
schützen natürlich muss man sich auf dem
Herbst vorbereiten wichtig wären auch
für den Herbst vor allen Dingen die
eigenen Pflegeheime zu schützen Kranken
die Gesundheitsämter mit den
hochkompetenten Kollegen sind ja die
ganze Zeit und einen Blickwinkel nicht
vernünftig eingesetzt wurden durch die
kontaktverfolgung und noch zu lange
durch kontaktverfolgung Quarantäne
Umsetzung sondern die Kollegen sind
super gut in
Hygienekonzepte in Prophylaxe Prävention
die können in den helfenden den
Altenpflegeheimen dort die Konzepte so
umzusetzen dass die Infektion der
älteren nach hinten geschoben wird dass
auch die Impfungen stattfinden dass man
auch das ein die Einfallstore
Pflegepersonal also da wäre viel zu tun
im Herbst aber jetzt auf 100% gesagt
jetzt müssen wir alles auf 100% oder das
steht ja auch falsch pandemiebekämpfung
heißt auch kalibriert zu agieren
situationsgerecht regional zeitlich
angebracht und wenn die Situation sich
etwas verschärft muss man die Maßnahmen
etwas verschärfen und was nehme ich
einfach schnell sagen was man braucht
für ein herzlichen Stufenplan wo man
klare Parameter Iden interessiert wie
man beobachtet
hospitalisierungsrate
intensivstationbelegung neueinweisungen
in den Krankenhäusern und auf die
Intensivstation und dann entsprechend an
diese Parameter auch Maßnahmen anbinde
sagt okay wenn Sie viel Prozent der
Person auf den Intensivstation
corona-patienten dann oder wenn sich das
andeutet dann wollen wir die und die
Maßnahme anziehen dann wollen wir wieder
Kontakt tragen in den
Innenräumen und so weiter kann man ja
alles eskalieren und dann ist das auch
eine vorhersagbare
[Musik]
bekämpfungsbekämpfungskonzept da nimmt
man die Menschen mit und das kann man
dann auch wieder runterfahren wenn die
Situation nicht verbessert also das
braucht man jetzt und nicht wieder so
aus der Hüfte schießen oder nur sagen
wir wollen Maske tragen das ist so wie
derjenige der dem Auto kaputt geht und
der sich überlegt funktioniert der
Hammer also nicht ja klar funktioniert
Name aber dafür funktioniert was dann im
Auto kaputt ist dass muss man erst mal
gucken was kaputt ist und so ist das
auch mit der Pandemie gemacht ja oder
nein natürlich zu machen aber ob man sie
braucht hängt von der Pandemie Situation
ab was mich noch zum Schluss
interessieren würde eben weil auch noch
so viele Fragezeichen aus ihrem Bericht
hervorgekommen sind und so geht es auch
Simone weiß heißgold bei Facebook sie
fragt sich und ich mich auch wird diese
Studie noch weitergeführt oder ist sie
somit abgeschlossen
abgeschlossen wird jetzt dem
Gesundheitsministerium gestern Abend
übergeben wurden der nächste Schritt ist
die Übergabe an den Bundestag wie die
beiden
Auftraggeber es ist auch eine der
vielleicht noch mal neu zu überlegenden
besseren Herangehensweisen wir die
Zukunft dass man eben
nicht die
Exekutive Organisation die ja eigentlich
bewertet werden soll mit den Maßnahmen
auch Vorschlagsrecht gibt die Leute zu
benennen die hineinkommen also ich fand
die Leute waren alle vollständig
unvoreingenommen haben jeden tollen Job
gemacht aber es gibt immer den Geruch
das Geschmäcker dabei du bist ja von der
Regierung vorgeschlagen sind die
Regierung ist ja eigentlich diejenige
Organisation die die ganzen Maßnahmen
umgesetzt hat also das könnte man die
auch noch mal überlegen aber noch mal
wieder knappe an Antwort nein fertig
jetzt geht's in die
Legislative die schauen sich das dann im
September
sagt Klaus Stöhr Mitglied des
Sachverständigenausschuss vielen Dank
dass Sie sich Zeit genommen haben heute
für unsere Fragen und dass sie bei uns
zu Gast waren
ja gerne ich bedanke mich
und es ist eben nicht schwarz-weiß es
ist nicht alles so einfach ich habe
gelesen in den Kommentaren dass ihr auch
ganz unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu
habt wir wissen alle haben alle schon
erlebt Corona das regt uns alle in
irgendeiner Form auf und ich möchte
schließen mit dem Kommentar von Boris
Kabale laschnikow bei Youtube kablassny
blasznikow mein Gott eure Namen bringt
mich an die Grenze aber er schreibt und
er bringt eben diese beiden Seiten auf
den Punkt der schreibt durch die
corona-pandemie gab es auch viele gute
Veränderungen er nennt für sich das
Homeoffice aber wie groß sind wohl die
psychischen Folgen der Menschen
insbesondere Kinder fragt er sich und es
zeigt ganz klar natürlich Corona hat
einfach zwei Seiten und damit beenden
wir schließen wir für heute und vielen
Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit dass ihr
zugeschaut habt bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]